Aaron Jones good to see you good to see
you thanks for having out pleasure to
have you here
what are your combine memories what was
that like for you uh it's a once in a
lifetime experience a long process but
something I wouldn't trade for the world
you a lot of long meetings uh long
doctor's visits and about time you get
ready to compete you're kind of tired
but you're athletes so you're there to
compete and it's time to go yeah I know
the early mornings right well what time
was the normal wake up for you know that
I think it was the day before we
competed drug test at like 3:00 a.m.
come on yeah knock on the door do you
gotta set your phone yourself or
something like that you gotta set your
phone yourself or you you you're pretty
much on your own schedule so you'd be
setting yourself back you'll be at the
end of the line and well pretty much get
to take your drug test of you the last
person in LA so yeah in the morning
during the morning come on so yeah I
know that's the one thing that a lot of
folks don't realize is that the on-field
drills that's the last thing you do that
is the absolute last thing that you do
oh yes definitely
a lot of psychological testing uh just a
whole bunch of testing what's the
strangest question you were asked I
don't think I got too many uh probably
just a my cat or a dog which team asked
you if you were kind of a dog you recall
ah I do not recall but it was actually
it was on a lot of the psychological
tests into whether you're a cat or a dog
okay well I mean it could be well I mean
dog would be the Browns right cat would
be Jaguars Panthers even things like
that lion I think of a mentality are you
so what how did you answer I said I was
a doll what you want that's how you
gotta answer it I mean you might you
might like you know drinking milk apps
or if you say you're a cat doesn't that
say I am just going to ignore you and
walk away from you whenever I damn
please right dog means you are loyal
you are there yes sir for you that's the
answer that's part of the reason why I
like Aaron Jones on the show and so what
did you run your
14 officially four five three on the
screen except for five oh so that's what
I stick with right okay and so what when
you were there did you met with McCarthy
is that who you met with him oh I met
with the Sr I was so I met with the head
coach the GM the officer coordinator the
running back coach the special teams
coordinator they're all sitting in one
hotel room they take out the beds in
there that rec desk and you sit there
you have your official your meeting with
them about 15 minutes and it can go one
of two ways I can go in there and grill
you on your college film or they could
compliment you and have you drawing up
stuff on the board and just to see what
you know and see your football IQ yeah
again Aaron Jones here in the Rich Eisen
show the for those who may not know what
you just described is the interviews
take place in a hotel in Indianapolis
that 51 other weeks of the year is there
for tourists to come in with an indoor
pool as well
definitely and you have to be careful
that you don't walk into it and that the
interview rooms are just regular rooms
that people stay and they remove the
beds the headboards are still attached
to the wall it's a weird situation
oh yeah is the host of the set up is the
train station I mean it's right when you
walk in the hotel room and they get your
earplugs and okay you might want to put
these in at night that's right it's near
the train comes through so that's
already waking you up right and then
your 15 minutes with your team is up
when somebody blows an air horn air horn
and then you get out you look at a
laminate around your neck to know to say
which would you go to and you try to
remember so you're not like so you're
organized you know which room you're
going to who you're meeting with so and
then they wake you up to pee in a cup at
3:00 in the morning and then have you
work out an entire day and then send you
to the airport and you're like what the
hell just happened
go onstage in front of the coaches and
just in your spandex it feels like a
little meat market I mean you go onstage
they caught your height weight nothing
but your spandex I mean I don't wanna
math Lisa
you're flexing you heard what I was
asking her like if he was flexing back
in his day I was on the stage flexing
hard you were I bet you were did you
leave thinking I think the Packers are
gonna take me if I'm there or what uh I
know who's gonna take me at the time I
was like I thought I was just happy I
had performed well I felt like I had
made a name for myself coming from UTEP
I felt like I was a kind of underdog so
not a lot of people knew about me but
after the compound I felt like I left
their people at least knew a little bit
about me or knew my name well they
certainly know your name now Aaron Jones
that's for damn sure
and then the way that you are bawling
out to me if you don't mind me
opinionated in front of you you weren't
used enough last year how would you
respond to something like that that
statement
oh I respond to that is I just I'm just
ready when my number is called a coach
told me go get in the game
I'll go get in the game and I'll make
the most of every opportunity I get I
think that's what everybody should do
and when you when you don't know when
your next steps gonna come you're gonna
when you try to make the best of every
opportunity and you're playing balls to
the wall excuse my language cool no
you're talking about footballs dukes no
but by the way that's a very clapping
for a very politically correct answer
over there very good job you're very
good at that very good at that part of
the game too look I mean cuz to me
everyone was talking about Rodgers
needing to have some sort of pressure
removed offensively you're the you're
the guy that can come out of the
backfield you can catch it we saw what
you did against Seattle what was it like
in the huddle with Aaron Rodgers towards
the end of the McCarthy stay there was
it as uncomfortable as as it was
reported to be at all no it was never
comfortable uncomfortable any time I had
been there I mean I'm not in the headset
so I don't know what's being said and
communicated in in the quarterbacks
headset but I know at least in the
huddle for us it was never uncomfortable
it was always clear-cut what we were
gonna do and go to line and it's a bad
look we're gonna audible it out of the
bad look and it's something we practiced
all week so what is Aaron Rodgers
relationship with you what does he say
to you what did what do you say to him I
love there I mean
he's a great guy he's a leader he he
just comes in he he makes sure
everybody's in the right mood like he's
getting you in the right mood if you
come in see see you down he's gonna joke
with you try to get pick you up
he'll just stop by and say how you doing
today this is just little things and you
know if the best player on your team can
do that anybody else can do that what do
you mean by pick you up like he sees if
you're down or something
yeah no energy or something like I mean
every it's a no-no nobody wants to come
into work every day people are gonna
have their their days where they don't
want to come in and I know his errand
has a sixth sense and he can sense that
and he'll come over there hey let's go
it's okay blah blah blah or we'll be on
the field and we'll stall it driving her
come out and he'll get on he'll get down
on his knee anyway alright this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna go down I'm
written I recall Dallas my rookie year I
think it was like a minute minute left
in the game comes down gets something
huddle gets on her knees say all right
yards over yards over time outs getting
out of balance get yards fires so the
classic is gets down we're gonna come
out and we're gonna win this game we're
gonna drop down and we're gonna win this
game and that was a back show to do
to Davante Adams and we win the game it
was just the playoff game and you know
this was during the regular season 2017
yes sir that's gotta mean something when
he comes in and he's basically say this
is what we're gonna do and then you go
ahead and do it
oh yeah sorry is that never ones doubt
and we came in I don't say that never
once right what have you had a
conversation with your new head coach I
actually did yes sir okay what did Matt
Lafleur tell you no no you just uh
saying like what kind of scene schemes
they use very similar to Tennessee and
what they do and they incorporate the
backs and I use the backs and it likes
to be balanced run a play-action run
game so I'm very excited so the way that
we saw Dion Lewis employed or the way
that we saw Derek Henry employed is what
the way that you're gonna be employed he
didn't really give me uh either one but
I'm just I've seen the way he used both
and I said previously and I'll and
another way he used Tevin Coleman and
Devonta Freeman and so that just excites
me like he knows how to use running
backs and I everybody knows they'll get
me wrong everybody knows how to use
running backs but you see him used the
two runner back system and he's like
okay you're you're cut for this you're
cut for that and I'm just trying to get
a sense of what what what you what's
your goal for next year then I mean cuz
again you had what I would think is a
breakout to me and again I'm I'll tell
you what I've been saying here you know
you the way that you were employed the
way that you looked as well you reminded
me in a way of what I was seeing from
Kareem hunt on the field obviously you
know that what I saw from him out of the
Chiefs I'm like that's that guy he can
be that guy for the Packers do you see
yourself as that guy well yes sir I feel
like I'm very similar to him as well as
Kumar I feel like I can do a little bit
of the same we can as well stretch the
field catch the ball out of the
backfield as well so I agree off okay
like them so what is your goal in I mean
for the Packers
our goal is to help us get back in the
playoffs and make it to the Super Bowl
that's alright that's the mango if your
latest game what do you think
me personally I want to lead the league
and Russian I want to lead the league in
yards per carry I want to lead the
league in touchdowns you know about how
obviously how difficult that is
obviously or let's put it this for
challenging yes sir that is who do you
reach out to on that front to for
guidance who is there any colleagues
that you have around the league or
something like that uh no god I mean
everything I do is do guys so I mean my
parents I'll reach out to them my
brother I have a twin brother who plays
reach out to him Alvin no sir Alvin at
the he's a linebacker in Baltimore yes
sir okay and you have a youth football
camp with with Alvin as well right over
1200 kids attended over two days last
year yes the Sun Bowl you're all about
El Paso huh yes sir this home this home
I love El Paso that is that's home for
me
have you met bed or work have you met
him I met him when I was in high school
once but not not recently okay
yes sir it's okay just want to know if
you've yeah I mean he's like kind of mr.
el Pasto right now along with you and
your brother and you were a salute to
service nominee what did you what did
you do with the salute service program
with the Packers oh well um about my
parents were retired military and I just
spent a lot of time giving back to the
military and so when that's a part of
what that award is just giving your time
and things you've done for the military
so the military's I've grown I've grown
up my dad did 29 years my mom did 27 and
so I've grown up in a military
background done so many things go on a
PT and with my dad and so many different
things so military is a big big for me
and I just want to thank them for their
uh their service and last one for you
you trained for the draft with mahomes
is that a fact
the ascertainment homes yes sir we are
the same agent okay and you drove to his
pro day I'm trying to figure out what
this is all about to Patrick's protein
uh yes sir I did me a powder boys and uh
we were in it together going through the
whole compound process and we were
putting in that work together and my pro
day came right a couple days right after
the combine so I I was just training I
had free time so I was like ever
catching balls from him he's getting you
buddy and you're getting him running yes
sir 20 of them no no no look passes all
right now he's shown he could do it out
there but he did I didn't catch any from
him not from it I'm a left-handed he
throwing left-handed yes don't laugh and
I've have seen him do that my gosh what
a year and what are your for you to man
I'm very pleased for you and to see what
you've done on the football field and
what the the future you're you're a
crucial component in my mind for what
the Green Bay Packers are going to do
this year any talk at all in in any
Packers circles I'm not talking
management by the Antonio Brown any
conversation no I mean the conversation
see on Twitter through from the fans and
even one in there but no nobody in the
locker room saying about 84 no no sir I
mean I have a text exchange with you or
any of your player of your teammates
talking about it to anyone no sir I had
to ask
you did a good job you didn't get
tattooed he had to okay well we look
great in Green Bay though what would you
think of him as a teammate I mean he's a
great player I love to play a B he's a
playmaker and the more playmakers you
can get on one team there's better l
beat him at Davante Adams you Aaron
Rodgers at the controls with the new
Davante Adams is very slept on he's very
sweet what do you mean by that
just I feel like a lot of people don't
give him give him his respect as they do
a lot of the other receivers across the
league he's more of a quiet guy he stays
to himself I mean you'll see him make a
catch in him he'll show himself a little
bit but he's not he's not out there as
everybody else is and so I feel like he
doesn't get the respect as everybody
else does because he's not he's not a
chess pounder yeah he he'll let you know
when he makes a play but he's not
hey I'm this that nut so okay well look
man company come here anytime at
Showtime with a Y underscore 33 on
Twitter and also Instagram the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience